real quick before it there's not too
much more to say about this the electors
are voting today okay uh the electors
that were uh that that are actually the
ones who carry out the election of the
president based on state popular vote
results are voting today the real
question is how many Republican electors
won't vote Trump and will we even know
today the formal electoral vote happens
today we may not know the exact results
for several weeks a quote from the
United States Code provision 15 of
chapter one of title three Congress
shall be in session on the sixth day of
January succeeding every meeting of the
electors the Senate and House of
Representatives shall meet in the hall
of the House of Representatives at the
hour of one o'clock in the afternoon on
that day and the president of the Senate
shall be there presiding officer of
course that is Joe Biden who will
supervise as lawmakers gather to tally
the electoral college votes that day
they're split opinion on this Pat
because 11 view is we first of all some
of the state electoral voting processes
are uh public so we'll know in some of
those states what the results are and if
after the electors cast their votes some
of them rebell or go rogue or vote for
someone other than who they were
expected to vote for based on their
state election it will become news
because they are going to be talked to
but at the same time that's not
necessarily the case so it could be at
least a while until we know the final
tally of how the electors vote today
yeah I think we could have a sense of
what happened based on the few people
that they do interview after this vote
takes place actually after these 50
votes take place uh but yeah I mean this
long national nightmare of the 2016
election cycle could continue into next
year indeed and it's probably going to
actually continue as a nightmare for at
minimum four years passively even a diff
if you know what I mean so yes that's
what's going on today we will see I
don't think there's anything more to say
we've reported about a variety of
different sources expecting and
anticipating that some Trump electors
are going to go rogue and not vote for
Trump we know about Christopher sopran
we've also heard from the Hamilton
electors we've heard from legal experts
about different rules in different
states about penalties and potential
fines for going rogue and not voting the
way that your state
popular vote went we're at the end here
and we will have news as the news comes
in we will have it for you part of that
news may be presented on Facebook live
i've been doing facebook live streams
and i encourage you to make sure you
like our facebook page facebook.com
slash david pakman show i do sometimes
go on in chat take questions etcetera
and you can bet that later today if
there is indeed news regarding the
Elector vote i will be on facebook live
at facebook.com slash david pakman show
talking about it